meine damen und herren danke dass sie
gewartet haben und guten morgen wir
haben heute intensiv gearbeitet
ich will noch einmal darauf hinweisen
wir kämpfen jetzt ja schon seit mehr als
einem jahr mit dem virus und gestern
inzwischen ist es ja früh morgens
geworden gestern exakt vor einem jahr
war es notwendig in anbetracht der
aufziehenden pandemie weitere
einschränkungen der sozialen kontakte
von jedem und jedem einzelnen zu
beschließen
und ich werde es nicht vergessen denn
unmittelbar nach dieser pressekonferenz
musste ich mich zu einer 14 tägigen
quarantäne zurückziehen
und dabei ging es mir wie seitdem so
vielen menschen in unserem land in
diesem jahr sind wir und wir heißt bund
und länder aber vor allem auch alle
menschen in deutschland gemeinsam einen
wirklich harten weg gegangen
ein wl weg mit erfolgen aber auch mit
rückschlägen und wir dürfen uns von
diesen rückschlägen natürlich nicht
entmutigen lassen
im gegenteil aus solchen rückschlägen
kann auch zusätzliche kraft erwachsen
und wir können ja auch sagen dass wir
heute so viel weiter sind als vor einem
jahr
die forscher verstehen dass wir uns
besser die ärzte können patienten besser
behandeln
jeder von uns weiß mit welchen
verhaltensweisen er sich und andere
wirksam schützt wir haben eine ganze
brand bandbreite von tests zur verfügung
vom pcr-test bis zum selbsttest und das
konnten wir vor einem jahr nun vor allen
dingen nicht voraussagen
die haben wirksame impfstoffe aber wir
haben eben das virus noch nicht besiegen
können
es lässt nicht locker und nachdem wir im
januar die infektionszahlen stark senken
konnten erleben wir durch das vordringen
der ansteckenden britischen mutante
jetzt immer klarer auch sichtbar die
gefährlichere mutation wir erleben genau
das gegenteil damit die freizeiten
steigen exponentiell die intensivbetten
füllen sich wieder und jetzt haben auch
mehr menschen im mittleren und jüngeren
alter schwere verläufe auch longo witt
ist ein phänomen das viele menschen
erreicht und wir wollen keine
überlastung unseres gesundheitswesens
das haben wir auf diesen ganzen langen
weg der pandemie geschafft und das
müssen wir auch in den nächsten wochen
schaffen wir sind in einem wettlauf mit
dem impfen das seine wirkung möglichst
schnell entfalten soll und für uns sind
zwei oberbegriffe entscheidend vorsicht
und flexibilität vorsicht und
flexibilität haben uns auch bei unserer
letzten bären bund länder runde am
dritten märz begleitet und wir haben
damals einen stufenplan beschlossen mit
öffnungen abhängig von incidents werten
und mit einer notbremse für den fall
wieder an steigender infektionszahlen
und dieser stufenplan bleibt natürlich
der wesentliche leitfaden der damals
schon am dritten märz mit einer
umfassenden test strategie ergänzt
wurden
aber wir haben eben die situation dass
wir hier auch in einer sehr ernsten lage
jetzt sind was das impfen anbelangt will
ich noch mal erinnern haben wir am
freitag wesentliche beschlüsse gefasst
um auch hier flexibilität einziehen zu
lassen durch die einbeziehung der
hausärzte und wir wissen je mehr
menschen geimpft sind umso mehr verliert
diese pandemie auch ihren schrecken und
je mehr geimpft sind umso mehr kann der
wert auch gesenkt werden und die
wissenschaft sagt uns ganz klar je
länger jetzt die je geringer jetzt die
neue infektion zahlen sind umso
schneller wirkt die impfung und je höher
die neue infektionszahlen sind umso
länger dauert es bis die impfungen
wirken und wir wollen natürlich dass er
die im führung möglichst schnell auch
ihre wirkung entfaltet und deshalb haben
wir heute sehr sehr lange und auch noch
mal sehr sozusagen neu gedacht wie wir
das bestmögliche in den nächsten tag
wochen erreichen können und ich habe
eben schon über die größere gefahr der
mutation gesprochen und deshalb müssen
wir mit unseren beschlüssen heute sagen
weil wir wieder im augenblick in einem
exponentiellen wachstum sind und zwar
sehr klar sichtbar klarer als das am
dritten märz abzusehen war dass wir
leider von der notbremse gebrauch machen
müssen
dort wo die incidents oberhalb von 100
ist und das ist leider in vielen kreisen
oder bundesländern der bundesrepublik
deutschland inzwischen wieder der fall
und wir müssen auch noch einmal darauf
hinweisen dass die vereinbarten öffnungs
schritte ja nur dann umgesetzt werden
können wenn die sieben tage instituts
unter 100 neuinfektionen stabil ist oder
abnimmt beide dinge also notbremse über
100 wieder zurück auf die dinge wie sie
vor dem oder bis zum 7 märz gegolten
haben oder aber eben das gilt für alle
incidents basierten öffnungs schritte
das will ich hier nochmal betonen oder
aber eben neue öffnungs schritte unter
100 nur dann wenn die fallzahl stabil
oder sinken
wir wissen dass allein die notbremse
nicht ausreichen wird um das
exponentielle wachstum zu beenden
deshalb müssen zusätzliche maßnahmen
ergriffen werden und dabei werden in
landkreisen mit einer sieben tage
instanz von über 100 weitergehende
schritte umgesetzt
und hier haben wir exemplarisch weil das
auch länderspezifische und regional
wahrgenommen wird
vorschläge gemacht einmal das tragen
medizinischer masken im privaten bereich
mitfahrer in einem auto sind die nicht
zum hausstand gehören weitergehende
verpflichtungen zu masken tragen
ausgangs beschränkungen und verschaffte
kontakt beschränkungen das sind
möglichkeiten die zusätzlich zu der
notbremse angewandt werden müssen
wir stehen vor ostern und wir fragen uns
wie können wir diese ostertage zu einer
ruhephase entwickeln
und deshalb haben wir uns sehr lange
darüber diskutiert wie wir einen beitrag
dazu leisten können diese dritte welle
vor der wir in der wir sind nicht vor
der wir stehen sondern der wir sind auch
ein stück weit das wird nicht vollkommen
gelingen zu durchbrechen und deshalb
sollen der erste april gründonnerstag
also und der dritte april einmalig als
ruhetage definiert werden mit
weitgehenden kontakt beschränkungen
sowie ein sammlungsverbot vom ersten bis
fünften april also eine erweiterte
ruhezeit zu ostern
was gilt damit an fünf zusammenhängenden
tagen das prinzip wir bleiben zu hause
private zusammenkünfte sind in dieser
zeit im kreis der angehörigen des
eigenen hausstands und mit einem
weiteren haushalt möglich jedoch auf
maximal fünf personen beschränkt kinder
wird das wissen sie bis 14 jahren werden
dabei nicht mitgezählt und paare ein
haushalt wir werden in dieser zeit
versammlung im öffentlichen ansammlungen
öffentlichen raum untersagen
außengastronomie soweit sie schon
geöffnet ist wird während dieser fünf
tage geschlossen und ausschließlich der
lebensmitteleinzelhandel im engen sinne
wird am samstag geöffnet
der bund wird einen vorschlag zur
rechtlichen umsetzung einschließlich der
begründung vorlegen und bund und ländern
werden auf dieser grundlage dann ihre
rechtsverordnungen vorlegen die
grundbasis der unseres vorgehens wird
das infektionsschutzgesetz sein
wir werden mit den
religionsgemeinschaften und dabei werden
bund und länder auf die
religionsgemeinschaften zu gehen mit der
bitte
an sie herantreten religiösen
versammlungen in dieser zeit nur
virtuell durchzuführen ich betone mit
der bitte und wir werden nur impf und
testzentren in der zeit geöffnet halten
nach ostern soll die phase der
umfangreichen testung beginnen auf der
grundlage eines dieses drei säulen
modells die tests in den bürger
testzentren die tests mit den
unternehmen und die tests in den schulen
und kitas hier soll dieses
flächendeckende testsystem auch wirklich
dazu dienen dass wir auch weitere
öffnungen dann ins auge fassen können
und wir wollen vor allen dingen ähnlich
wie das in tübingen heute schon gemacht
wird oder zum teil auch in rostock im
rahmen von zeitlich befristeten
modellprojekten in ausgewählten regionen
mit strenge schutzmaßnahmen und einem
test konzept einzelne bereiche des
öffentlichen lebens wieder öffnen um zu
lernen wie die umsetzbarkeit von
öffnungs schritten auch wirklich mit
einem test regime möglich ist die
unternehmen sagte ich schon bilden eine
weitere säule dieses test regimes der
erwarten dass sie bis anfang april einen
umsetzungsbericht vorlegen wir werden
eigene erhebung auch unternehmen und
werden dann auf der grundlage der uns
vorliegenden informationen bewerten ob
wir regulatorischen handlungsbedarf in
der arbeitsschutzverordnung noch
zusätzlich anwenden müssen
wir wissen dass einige unternehmen auch
gerade durch die jetzt noch einmal
vereinbarten schritte durch die
notbremse natürlich enttäuscht sind und
auch in ihrer geschäftstätigkeit weiter
eingeschränkt sind deshalb werden wir
für unternehmen die besonders schwer und
über eine sehr lange zeit von
schließungen betroffen sind ein
ergänzendes hilfsinstrument im rahmen
der europarechtlichen vorgaben
entwickeln wir haben uns dann sehr lange
mit den reisen beschäftigt wir raten von
allen reisen ins ausland ab in
risikogebiete reisen in risikogebiete
verursachen eine
quarantäne pflicht und bei virus
varianten gebieten ist dies noch
strikter und wir halten insgesamt eben
reisen für im augenblick nicht sehr
förderlich um das vorsichtig
auszudrücken und wir das versuchen
deshalb alles zu unternehmen dass
rückkehrer aus urlaubszielen auch
möglichst keinen neuen infektionsherde
zu uns bringen
deshalb haben wir mit den
fluggesellschaften vereinbart dass tests
von cruise und passagieren vor dem
rückflug stattfinden mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schaue
ich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren